SAM: Without further
ado, I'd like to
introduce the first panel.
Our moderator is James Pearce,
who does Dev Rel for Facebook.
He tells me that he now spends
about half of his time doing
stuff on native.
But his first love
is still the web.
And so it's highly appropriate
that he's going to be taking
this really crucial session
about mobile performance.
So take it away, James.
Thank you.
JAMES PEARCE: All right.
Well, welcome everybody.
As Sam said, this is the
performance panel.
I was honored to be invited
to come and moderate it.
I guess Facebook's recent
history with mobile and the
web has been relatively
well documented.
It's, as Michael said, the
Zuckerberg quote is "the gift
that keeps giving." But we
have obviously made a
commitment on our apps anyway,
on the Facebook apps, to
producing the best possible
quality experience as we can.
And we've ended up rewriting
both of our iOS and Android
apps to be pure native, where
they were previously hybrid
HTML5 in a wrapper
kind of apps.
And if I summarize starkly the
decision we made there, it was
performance.
There was only one reason
why we did that.
We had to retrain literally
hundreds of developers.
We had to retool our entire
build chain to produce iOS and
Android apps where we'd
been previously
building a pure web stack.
And pixel for pixel, the old
web app and the new native
apps were indistinguishable.
Not anymore, but if you'd put
them side by at the time, it
was very, very difficult to
tell which was which.
And the only way you could tell
they were different was
the performance.
And overnight, pretty much, our
ratings in the App Store
for the iOS app went from
two stars to four stars.
And let me just say again, it
was nothing to do with the
pixels or the appearance or
the rendering or the drop
shadows or anything.
It was purely the performance
and the increased user
experience of that.
So it was because of mobile web
performance that we had to
make this incredible
investment.
And we really didn't want
to have to do that.
So I'm here mostly to moderate
and channel your questions and
channel the questions off
the moderator here.
But also I'm going to say,
dude, where's my
60 frames per second?
You honestly promised
us this years ago.
The web was going to catch up.
But we haven't got it.
And businesses like ours and
businesses around the world
are still struggling
with this problem.
So I have a panel here of four
distinguished experts, two
from the Chrome team and two
from external companies.
I'd like them to introduce
themselves.
We have Paul, Tom,
Ilya, and Ariya.
A couple of minutes each if
you wold like, just to
introduce yourselves, please.
PAUL BAKAUS: Hi, everybody.
My name is Paul Bakaus.
I am the W3C rep and
CTO for a studio
called Studio 5 at Zynga.
And we're basically on a mission
to build what we think
is the next generation
of social games.
And we think HTML5 is the
right platform for that.
We've been operating in stealth
mode for quite a bit,
but now we're starting to roll
out our first experiments.
And lots of them really involve
performance with terms
like instant play.
We want to make people play
the games instantly.
And that's where we think HTML5
comes really into play.
All right, that's me.
TOM WILTZIUS: Hi, I'm
Tom Wiltzius.
I'm a product manager on the
Chrome team, working across
graphics projects including
Canvas, WebGL, but also core
rendering performance.
So I am on the other side
of all of this.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Hi, everyone.
My name is Ilya.
So I'm a developer advocate on
Make the Web Fast and Google
Chrome teams.
And my focus has primarily been
on the network side-- so
specifically for mobile
performance latency, how do we
accelerate that?
So HTTP 2.0, SPDY, and just
trying to figure out what we
can do to move the web forward
and to enable richer apps that
are still efficient when
delivered over the web.
ARIYA HIDAYAT: Hi, everyone.
My name is Ariya.
I work for Sencha.
We produce frameworks, tools,
and cloud surfaces for web
application, both desktop
and mobile.
I have a general interest
in web technologies.
I have been mainly the native
guy for a very long time.
I worked on WebKit when
I was with Nokia.
And then two years ago, 2 and
1/2 years ago, I decided to
switch sides and try to find out
how painful or comfortable
it is working with front-end
development.
JAMES PEARCE: So now that you
know who everybody is, that's
a great opportunity for you to
think of the hardest question
you would like to ask
each of them.
And hopefully you all have the
moderator page up, so you can
ask them there or simply
raise your hand.
But to get started with, well,
I was thinking about this.
Mobile performance, there's no
one thing that contributes to
performance.
It's a blend of lots of
different disciplines.
And we expect developers to be
masters of all of them in
order to produce highly
performant apps.
Sometimes it's going to be the
GPU that's the impact or the
major effect on their
performance.
Sometimes it's going to be
the network performance.
Sometimes it's going to
be JavaScript runtime.
So given that the average
developer is looking at this
huge surface area of problem
that they have to solve, where
should they start first?
What are the major performance
pain points that you see from
your points of view?
I guess we'll start at this
end and go down again.
PAUL BAKAUS: OK, so I think
it depends on what you're
building, really.
But I think if you're building
web apps and websites, it's
mostly about load time
performance.
I would see load time
performance being the biggest
bottleneck right now.
There's been recent studies
that e-commerce sites have
been degrading in terms
of performance--
I think over 40% percent
or something.
And that's very, very
worrying to me.
And on mobile, it's
even worse.
If the website loads
in over 10 seconds,
most people drop off.
And of course, it's not entirely
the fault of the
website and the browser.
It's also network performance,
network latencies.
But I think that's
an area where we
should focus on first.
With games, as longer-lived the
sessions are for your app
or for your game, the more you
have to focus, obviously, on
runtime performance, memory
management, lots of stuff.
But I would start
with load time.
TOM WILTZIUS: Yeah, I suppose
I'm a bit biased in that I
work on rendering performance,
so that's probably what I'm
going to say is the most
important thing.
But I do think that we are
moving to this world where
people expect a lot more out
of web applications.
We're moving from this world
of e-commerce sites and the
like, which are strongly rooted
in the tradition of the
web as document viewer, and
we're moving much more towards
applications where we expect
real-time performance.
And I'll call out James's point
earlier about needing to
retrain this entire corps of
Facebook developers to do
native mobile app development
and how painful that was.
But I think it's in some ways
unrealistic to expect that the
same developer skill set that
applied to building the old
generation of web applications,
which were very
rooted in, again, a document
viewer-type model--
it's unrealistic to expect
that skill set to cleanly
apply to an application that
you're expecting to do
something very different.
When you're expecting 60
frames a second and
complicated UI animations and
transitions, you're building a
different beast.
It's going to require a
different set of skills.
So I think the entire community
does need to prepare
for and expect appropriately
that a lot of reeducation is
going to be required.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I
work in networks.
And I'm also biased.
But I'll second what
Paul was saying.
But I'll also add a few more
things, which is there's
obviously the first experience
when you first load the page.
And then there's the rest of the
experience, which is your
app is loaded, and then the
frames per second and
everything matters.
So it's not a question
of either/or.
And I would say, if the question
is where do you
start, I would actually
say it's neither
one of these three.
So internally, we have been
talking about render, compute,
and network.
Those are the three pillars
of performance.
And the moment you fix one,
you're on to the next.
And then you unlock the
next bottleneck.
So the place to start is to
actually invest into analytics
to figure out where is my
problem to begin with.
It's not a question of, I know
rendering, so all I'm going to
focus on rendering.
It's like, well, if your
bottleneck is compute, that's
where you should start.
So in the network world, at
least, we have put a lot of
effort into developing tools
like real user measurement
such that you can gather real
data from real users and real
hardware and then figure out
that, hey, no, it really is a
problem on 3G, for example,
from our users to download
these apps.
And I know you guys have done
a lot of work to figure out
how to get the games down in
sub-three seconds or even
sub-one second.
PAUL BAKAUS: That's
right, yeah.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And that's a
really interesting challenge.
TOM WILTZIUS: I will also say
that's an area where we are
way behind on the rendering
side of things.
Your ability to measure in
fields anything about how your
rendering performance is, it's
really hard, to the point
where you sort of can't do it.
And I think that's the kind of
thing we've talked about, for
instance, in the web performance
working group,
about what we might be able
to do about that.
But I think we're not really
closing in on a solution yet,
largely because
implementations vary so wildly.
So if anyone has bright ideas
about what they would like to
see from a field analytics
API for rendering, I'd
love to hear it.
ARIYA HIDAYAT: So in my opinion,
evangelism is one
thing that we need
to work better.
We need to come up with better
vocabulary to the developers.
Those who work in the front end
development space, they
probably never studied
computer science.
So if I'm being given the task
by my manager to build the
mobile side of the company, and
then suddenly I need to
know everything from GPU
compositing to JavaScript Just
In Time Compiler, garbage
collector, and other
thingamajig, this is
all scary stuff.
So that's one thing that
we need to work more.
And another thing is also to
give the understanding that,
performance not only, but
optimizing the passport,
meaning that the bits and piece
from the server and the
client, with the rise of
single-page application, your
apps might run for a while.
So for example, if you build an
address book, and sorting
your contacts, 10 contacts if
10 miliseconds, it doesn't
mean that they will scale nicely
if you use bubble sort.
So scalability is also important
with respect to
performance and not only
time measurement.
JAMES PEARCE: So it sounds to
me like there are lots of
individual technical things
we need to think
about here as well.
But there is an overall cultural
issue, which is that
developers who think the web
is something they can just
lash up in a text editor are now
being dropped into a very
different world where they are
being expected to use tools
with 40-character long command
lines and huge, big log spews
that they have to visualize
and so forth.
So we can come back to some
of the technology, but I'm
intrigued by this because
there's a tooling piece here,
which is going to make it
a lot easier for people.
And there's best practices
around how they should
instrument their apps, both at,
presumably, development
time but also at run time.
Maybe the two of you could talk
a little bit about what's
happening on Chrome, and then
we're going to talk about some
other browsers, too,
if you don't mind.
So just give us a quick rundown
on tools and education
and instrumentation as is
it pertains to Chrome.
TOM WILTZIUS: Sure.
You want to kick it off?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Sure.
So for network, I'll highlight
one, which is actually
cross-browser, which is
Real User Measurement.
So this is a new API--
well, relatively new.
It's supported by all the modern
browsers where when the
page loads, you can actually
query it to say, give me all
the time stamps for the sequence
of the loading of the
page-- so anything from TCP
connection time to there was a
redirect to this is how much
time it took to load.
And the cool thing about this
is that once you have this
data, this is from a
real user on a real
device on a real network.
You can beacon it back to your
analytics, aggregate it, and
then segment it in a bazillion
different ways and actually
run meaningful A/B
experiments.
You can actually figure out that
this connection took this
long and so forth
and so forth.
So this alone I think has
changed the network
performance conversation in a
dramatic way, now that we can
gather this data.
We need something like
that for GPU.
And maybe it's as simple as
sampling this data and
beaconing back via a
similar mechanism.
TOM WILTZIUS: Yeah.
And that's definitely the kind
of thing, again, where we're
interested in trying
to explore.
But it is challenging
because the notion--
people ask for things like,
well I just want how many
frames a second am I getting.
That's actually not a meaningful
question to ask,
because in a multi-threaded
browser, you can have one to
four answers to this question.
And you get a different number
of answers depending on what
browser you're running in.
So from a cross-browser
tooling or analytics
perspective, I think rendering
is one of the toughest because
it's one of the areas where the
browsers have evolved most
differently.
But I think we are moving
towards a world where a
combination of some of the CSS
features that have been speced
and the performance needs of
the platform are forcing a
slow reconvergence of how a
lot of these things work.
So I'm cautiously optimistic
that, in the future, we'll be
able to instrument some of
these things better.
Sorry, go ahead.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So for Chrome
DevTools, we put in a lot of
effort into instrumenting all
the right bits of the stack so
that you can get at the
root of the problem.
But I think that one challenge
that we have today is you
still need a lot of education
to know what to look for.
You need to run the trace,
and then you're
looking at this waterfall.
And you need training.
I know that when I sit
down with somebody--
with yourself or Paul-- and I
see you guys go through the
whole workflow, I'm like, oh,
there's five tricks I was
never aware of just because
I never thought about it.
So what we can do, I think, a
better job of is actually
giving these kind of insights
to developers, to say here's
an anti-pattern.
Let's flag it.
Let's put a red flag beside it
and have a Learn More link.
This is the culture piece.
We need to educate people about
what these things are.
I think we've done a fairly good
job on the network side
because we've been tackling
that problem for longer.
Rendering and other things,
we have a lot of room for
improvement.
PAUL BAKAUS: Well I just wanted
to say, one big issue,
I think, with rendering
performance and measuring
rendering performance is because
it's harder to isolate
it on the actual device--
because it might be entirely
the user fault why
rendering is down.
He might have lots of apps open
that do something in the
background and that
consume memory.
And then text just keep swapping
from memory spaces.
And that's something that I
think is fairly difficult,
because if you get reports in
from the same device-- let's
say a Nexus device--
but to completely randomize,
it's very hard to construct
data out of that.
I think that's a
real challenge.
TOM WILTZIUS: I think to an
extent that is a challenge
with network performance as
well, though, because it's
entirely possible that,
oh, some app
is swamping my loadable--
PAUL BAKAUS: App congestion.
TOM WILTZIUS: Yeah, exactly.
It's the nature of a shared
resource, right?
I do think though-- to get back
to your original question
about what are some of the best
tools available, at least
in Chrome, for debugging
rendering performance--
compared to where we were maybe
a year ago, we do have
some features that are
relatively simple and
incremental, but you get a lot
of mileage out of them.
These are things like the
Vertical Timeline.
We have rearchitected the way
our paint rectangle visibility
feature works.
To work with the latest actual
under-the-hood rendering
pipeline, we have a mode that
continuously repaints the
entire page, which helps you
diagnose what is taking a long
time to paint.
These are relatively simple
things, but they can actually
go a pretty long way
in debugging sites.
And I know I was talking to Paul
Lewis, one of our other
developer advocates, just before
this talk about people
who were coming by earlier at
the Chrome Perf Alley thing
over at Moscone, and, I think,
often weren't aware that this
was a big problem or weren't
aware of how they would even
begin to start addressing this
but, with a little bit of
education about how to use these
tools, actually came
away with a lot of things
that they could go
investigate on their own.
So I think, yes, that
is cultural.
Yes, that is educational.
And I think we're starting
to have some better
tools in this space.
But for the really hard cases,
we're still not there.
ARIYA HIDAYAT: So related to the
performance and tools, we
also need to educate developers
to include
performance metric as part of
their development workflow.
For example, you build
a fantastic game.
You've built a nice scroller,
nice apps, and it scrolls
beautifully.
And then suddenly some intern,
junior engineer, whoever, are
checking some code.
Probably he has a good
intention, but the performance
drops from 60 frames per second
to 30, and there's no
way to detect that.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So can I
add just one thing?
So prior to focusing on network
performance, I was
actually part of the Google
Analytics team, so there's my
another bias.
Performance is a feature.
When we talk about your
performance drops, your
conversion drops, your
engagement drops, we have good
measurements--
as you mentioned before, where
convergence dropped by 4%.
There's not many features you
can add to an e-commerce site
that will bump your revenue
per user by 4%.
So it is a feature
like any other.
It should be prioritized on your
backlog like any other.
It's not a sprint that
you do at the end to
clean up your app.
It's like, I'm going to build
this thing, and then I'm going
to fix performance.
You can't slap on performance,
just like you can't slap on
security at the end.
So invest early into measuring
this stuff.
How does this actually translate
to my users?
I think this is a very,
very important metric.
JAMES PEARCE: All right, I want
to do a little straw poll
here if possible.
How many people here in the
audience, if you're developing
for mobile and you're developing
for the mobile web,
if you find a performance
problem, do you
know what to do?
Do you feel like you have all
the tools you need to be able
to go and diagnose it?
Do you feel you have the
understanding about network
GPU, especially in the mobile
case, to go and solve that?
Who feels that they are totally
tooled up and ready to
go, cross-browser,
cross-device.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES PEARCE: Nobody.
OK, so there's obviously
work to be down.
But I think cross-browser
thing is important.
And I know this is predominantly
a Chrome
session, but I think--
oh, it's Deon.
Deon, where are you?
You have a question which,
I think, is to
do with other browsers.
Would you like to stand
up and ask?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Hi, Deon [INAUDIBLE]
Labs.
And so you set up my question
very nicely.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you
have the mic?
JAMES PEARCE: I'm wondering
whether A/V is easier or
harder than web performance
at this point?
[LAUGHTER]
ARIYA HIDAYAT: It's wired.
They should have the
wireless mic.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So we have that exact
pain point.
The Chrome Developer
Tools are amazing.
There's good developer tools
across other browsers
and that like that.
But I watch all the developers
on the team coming up with
this problem on some ancient
Android browser that's being
used by someone in the UK or
some BlackBerry user or
someone else.
And they have to go and re-learn
a different tool for
everything.
It's like the equivalent that
we've joked about before,
where you have "Friends" is
really successful on TV, and
then you've got to
make the DVD.
And you've got to re-cast
everyone and film it again
from scratch.
It just is so painful.
And then you get the Sony
MiniDisc version that just has
your buddies in it.
So is there any hope
coming there?
TOM WILTZIUS: To a certain
extent, this is a pretty
difficult thing you're asking
for, because the point of many
independent but interoperable
implementations of web
browsers is that the
implementations are different.
So if what you really want is
visibility into the guts of
the thing, which is, I think,
often what people ask for,
then that's tough.
I think, honestly, the real
hope is two-fold.
One, the performance pain points
that are most obvious
and most easy to stumble on will
be ironed out over time
as those real legacy browsers
go away and modern browsers
care a lot more and compete with
each other to try to stay
performant.
And then from a standardization
perspective,
we get very good APIs defined
and everyone sticks to them.
We're doing a lot of work to
make sure that, especially in
a world with Blink, another
rendering engine, we stay as
interoperable as possible when
it comes to spec compliance.
But people don't spec
performance.
So what we're relying on to make
sure performance is just
good is competition
between browsers.
I think that's healthy.
I think that's going to work.
And hopefully that will push
the performance ceiling--
or floor, depending on
how you look at it--
to a point where you don't need
to worry as much about
huge differences like these
cliffs existing only in some
browsers but not in others.
And we'll get to only things
that are fundamentally,
because of the specification
or something, too slow, and
then we can have conversations
about how we can improve them
by changing the APIs.
JAMES PEARCE: So Paul, I'm
guessing you probably have a
fairly large surface area that
you're looking to deal with,
and you do have perf specs.
You do know what frames per
second you have to get to.
PAUL BAKAUS: That's right.
JAMES PEARCE: Would you like
to share those with us?
PAUL BAKAUS: Well, first of
all, I wanted to say that,
regarding the specs, I think
it's super odd that
performance is not
part of spec.
And I've been talking about
this on the W3C-level odd.
And what's weird is that in most
other standards bodies,
performance is actually
part of spec.
So in the LTE spec, for
instance, performance is a
large part of it.
And I find it super odd that
it's not being done on the
W3C, level.
So that's first.
And so, on the product side, we
are also taking performance
very seriously from the start
and adding it to the spec.
So we'd like to be at
60 FPS for run-time
performance, sure.
We have goals to stay below
three seconds for load time,
at least on Wi-Fi And LTE.
If you're on a 3G connection,
all bets are off, because even
just activating the radio signal
to the next cell can
take up to a couple seconds.
So at that point, you don't have
much influence over it.
But yes, I think the point about
regression that Ariya
mentioned is a good point,
because if you have it in a
spec really early, performance
metrics for your features,
what you want to build, you
start thinking about it
differently.
And with every commit, you
continue measuring if it
degraded your performance
or not, whether
you're still on track.
And I think that that's what's
super important, not
specifically whether you're
looking for to have your
upload in three or five seconds,
but really just
making sure you have a spec.
JAMES PEARCE: And what is your
target device portfolio?
Do you set the floor at a
particular version of a
particular browser?
And--
by the way, I'm interested--
what do you do for users that
happen to have an
inappropriately poor device?
PAUL BAKAUS: So I'm happy to
say that the stuff we're
building right now has
a fairly large
set of browser support.
So, for instance, on Android,
we're targeting
Gingerbread and up--
which is, as you know if you've
worked with Android on
mobile performance, Gingerbread
is quite a
challenge because it only
has the stock browser.
Well, I'm not sure if you can
install Chrome mobile on
Gingerbread.
I don't think you can.
ARIYA HIDAYAT: You can
install Opera.
PAUL BAKAUS: You can install
Opera, but not many people do
it, I think.
At least that's my guess.
I don't have data on it.
Sorry about that.
But yeah, it's a
real challenge.
That being said, I also think
there's a place to build games
and apps that push the edge.
I just wrote a blog post
about this, actually.
I was arguing that many managers
really think HTML5 in
particular has a performance
issue.
I don't think that's fair.
I think no user complains--
well, some do, but I argue
they're stupid.
But usual users don't complain
that their latest PC game
doesn't run well on their
10-year-old Windows XP computer.
But people do with HTML5.
I see managers trying to load
apps in IE8 on bad hardware,
and they're complaining
about it.
And that has to stop.
That's just not fair.
And I think we need
to push it more.
ARIYA HIDAYAT: So we can also
view it from a different
perspective.
How many of you here have
heard about RoboHornet?
Oh, good.
So the idea behind this
benchmark is to come up with a
common set, bearing any standard
performance metrics
from the standard bodies, that
can be run in all browsers.
And that should be, if you've
got the buy-in from the
browser vendors--
for example, inserting a
thousand rows in the table
should not get slower as the
browser gets new release.
For example, IE12 should not be
slower compared to IE11 or
IE10 with respect to doing
that kind of stuff.
So if that is part of the
development workflow from the
browser vendor themself, then
they know for sure that, hey,
if I degrade this performance,
then some real-world
application like Google Apps
or frameworks like Sencha
Touch Mobile that will have
a performance impact.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So getting back
to the tooling question across
different platforms, I think we
have some good answers for
the network side.
So for example, we have project
open source products
like WebPagetest which allow
you to run a test against
different browsers-- so IE,
Chrome, and the rest-- and get
the same visual output.
And that is already a great
start because I know DevTools
really, really well, but I
haven't been using the IE
tools for a while.
So at least now, you can put
them side by side and say,
here's A. Here's B. And now I
can compare the waterfalls and
compare that.
And we've developed, basically,
bottom-up specs for
that-- so HTTP Archive Spec,
where we can right-click on
the waterfall and export
it and import it
into a different tool.
We have an export for the
Timeline in Chrome, but we
don't have a tool.
It would be cool if you could
export a rendering timeline
from Firefox and also have a
similar tool where you could
compare them and say, I'm
getting x FPS here and y FPS
over there.
That's all doable, I think.
TOM WILTZIUS: Yeah, again,
modular the fact that people
ask for FPS not realizing that
this is a difficult thing to
really standardize what
the term even means.
But your point's absolutely
a good one.
And actually I'll tie that to
what we were saying about
measuring performance
regressions.
We have a framework, I guess I'd
call it, that we've used
to monitor Chrome performance
as we develop Chrome.
It's called Telemetry.
It's something you
can go check out.
We have some documentation on
the Chromium Dev site if
you're interested.
But basically it's a Python
harness that talks to Chrome
via the Chrome Developer Tools
protocol and instructs it to
do simple things like load a
page, scroll it, get a bunch
of stats back out.
But again, these are
implementation-specific stats,
which is painful.
But then we can monitor for
like scrolling performance
regressions, for instance.
And if people like external
developers want to plug their
own content into this and keep
the version of Chrome fixed
but iterate on that content, I
think this could be a useful
tool for that.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I think what
we can do to make that better
is make it simpler.
TOM WILTZIUS: And then make
it work across browsers.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Because if you
would do a WebPagetest, as I
come to a web page, I type in,
literally, the name of the
page, and I just say
IE10 or IE9.
And I'm done.
Right now to run Telemetry,
it's like, yeah, check out
Chromium and just build it.
It's like, look.
And then there's the fact
that it's a [INAUDIBLE]
checkup.
TOM WILTZIUS: It does work
with stock Chrome matter.
But yeah, your point's
a good one.
And I wonder--
I don't know if we need to get
buy-in from other browser
vendors or what-- how
we can make this
work with other browsers.
We need a standard way of
communicating from outside the
browser in.
JAMES PEARCE: So we actually
have a related question on the
moderator here, which is
the from Andre Behrens.
Here?
No?
Yes.
Would you like to come up and
ask it regarding Chrome
performance versus--
ANDRE: Sure.
JAMES PEARCE: You're
on record.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDRE: Great.
Yeah, my question was simply--
I have a pretty heavy
app that I work on--
why is the performance on
certain things quick as the
dickens on an iPad currently
and not on a Nexus 10?
Are they cheating?
Is there a hardware cheat?
Or is it just enough time?
Or where are the slowdowns at?
Because I notice
them sometimes.
It's a lot better, but
I notice them.
TOM WILTZIUS: You're talking
about rendering
performance, I assume?
ANDRE: Yes.
TOM WILTZIUS: Or do you have
specific operations in mind?
ANDRE: The one that really gets
me is touch response and
rendering after the
touch response.
And I'm doing a big,
heavy, nasty thing.
It's that I'm moving a lot
of DOM nodes around.
But on the Pixel, it's
really great.
On my computer, it's
On the iPad, it's
really great.
On most Android devices,
it's pretty good.
And I'm wondering what
the difference is?
TOM WILTZIUS: Yeah, so some of
this is a resource question.
I love the comparison between
iPads and iPhones and Android
devices because it shows we're
in the same league, even
though they're half the price.
But I do think that it remains
a challenge for us to make
good on all the performance
promises of comparison.
So to a certain extent,
we have our work
cut out for us there.
But it is something we're
working on very hard, and
hopefully we'll just get
better underneath you
as time goes on.
The latest versions of Chrome
for Android, which is to say
those that have come out in
the last few months, have
actually a radically different
rendering architecture than
the ones that came out,
say, at this time last
year, at I/O 2012.
And we're going to continue
making changes at almost that
big a pace.
So right now, one of the things
we're looking at, for
instance, is what can we do
about input latency, which
it's probably not
the exact silver
bullet for your problem.
But it's very much related.
And part of Chrome's very
complicated multi-process
architecture is that we do a
lot of threat hopping, and
this is really hurting
performance when it comes to
input latency.
This is something
we're looking at
revamping right now.
So our hope is a lot of
this will get better.
I don't think there's anything
fundamental here.
I do want to point out
one other thing
though, which is also--
I don't want to make excuses,
but it is a lot more
challenging to change things
that are so related to things
like touch input because they we
work across five operating
systems, not one.
And that's a major challenge.
JAMES PEARCE: OK.
We're actually a little
pushed for time.
Time flies when you're
having fun.
But I did have one final
question, and then we're going
to go around with
the conclusion,
which is perhaps related.
I'm not sure if there's a GPU
issue or a networking issue.
But I have a very specific
question from Charles Ying,
which is, are there any efforts
in place to optimize
the power consumption
of Chrome right now?
This is something that web
developers have never really
thought about before, but
now they do have to.
TOM WILTZIUS: I can speak to
this one if you want to.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I'm curious
about the "do have to." Do you
have a good example in mind?
Is that something that you
guys optimize for?
JAMES PEARCE: Well on the
assumption that people spend
25% of their time on smartphones
on Facebook, I
suppose we have a responsibility
to make sure
it's not using up their
batteries too much.
But I would imagine the
same goes for games.
You don't want to be the,
quote, "app that is
responsible for killing
someone's battery in a day."
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I think
maybe a year ago--
we were just talking
before this panel--
talking about FPS in a browser
was a new concept
for a lot of people.
I think talking about battery
life today in a browser is a
new concept for a lot of people
because, what do you mean?
I'm just rendering a web page.
That is not the case, because
we're building apps.
And these apps are running
for a long time.
They have memory leaks.
They have other things.
On networking side, there are
lots of great examples where
we're doing things
wrong today--
things like, let me just slap
on a real time analytics
beacon on my page, because
it's awesome.
I get a nice vanity dashboard
that shows me the number of
people on my site.
And then every five seconds,
you're pinging the radio and
just burning the fricking
battery on the device.
And so those are good examples
of where we need
to fix these patterns.
I think we need to educate
developers.
We need to educate the companies
that are building
these things.
Google Analytics actually
addressed this
about a year ago.
But I've done a recent survey of
other real-time analytics.
They're all doing the
same problem.
TOM WILTZIUS: Yeah, I think, to
be perfectly honest, from a
rendering standpoint, we are
so bottlenecked on core
performance right now that power
consumption, while we
definitely worry about
it, it's lower on our
hierarchy of worries.
And the reason is that, as we
improve performance, we are
only going to improve
power consumption.
So right now, to scroll a web
page in Chrome for Android on
an older generation Nexus
device-- so a Nexus S or
something-- yeah?
Greg, you want to
say something?
GREG SIMON: Yeah.
TOM WILTZIUS: Burns all
your CPU, which
burns all your power.
So we got to fix that.
GREG SIMON: Yeah, we do care
a lot about power.
And we're actually working right
now on making changes to
our Telemetry, which is a Python
framework for running
tests on Chrome Desktop, Chrome
OS, Chrome on Android.
So we're working on
making changes to
actually measure power.
Sorry, I am Greg Simon.
I work with the Blink
team and others.
ARIYA HIDAYAT: So in some cases,
this also needs some
cooperation from the
hardware vendor.
For example, Qualcomm has
a very nice profiler.
I can't remember the name.
But that gives you the exact
measurement of the consumption
from the radio to the GPU.
And that's very important
metrics because if I build my
game using WebGL and then
suddenly it burns more power
than as if you would have
written with [INAUDIBLE], then
that's not good proposition.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And I just want
to add, one thing I'd love to
see as part of either DevTools
or any sort of tool chain is,
for example, visibility
into the radio.
Paul, you mentioned that
sometimes just turning on the
radio takes, literally,
seconds and
burns a lot of battery.
Having understanding and
visibility into how the radio
operates can have
a huge impact.
We don't have any
instrumentation across any platform.
Even the native apps don't
really have good
instrumentation.
I was looking-- so Qualcomm
is a great example.
AT&T actually has
a great tool.
There's basically no other tool
where you can actually
record a session on your
phone, and then--
it's not an exact measurement--
but it will
model the radio states and the
actual battery consumption.
It'll tell you, this
app consumed x
many joules of energy.
And that's a start.
JAMES PEARCE: Cool.
We have time, I think, for one
question from the floor.
AUDIENCE: So we were talking
about actual performance and
real numbers and what we could
do to improve things, but we
were also talking about
the education.
Do you think we should put
more time into educating
people about perceived
performance?
Because we only have certain
limits that we have right now,
like 3G, so should we talk more
about, not fall-backs,
but different angles of how to
make things better for users
without building new devices?
PAUL BAKAUS: Oh, yeah.
I would say absolutely.
I think that's a great point.
As internal at Zynga, we always
think about actual
performance and perceived
performance, responsiveness.
And that starts with
easy stuff.
If you click a button,
make it do something
while you're waiting.
Or if you're loading your
page, show a loader.
Do something.
Put something out to the user,
so that anxiety of waiting
isn't perceived the same way.
And there's all kinds of
techniques to do that, and I
think it's important to educate
people about those.
JAMES PEARCE: Any interest in
getting one more question in?
Do you want a question?
AUDIENCE: No, actually, I want
to answer the power question.
JAMES PEARCE: Oh, wants to
answer the power question.
Unless anyone has any more
on that previous point?
TOM WILTZIUS: No, you should
let Chris go for it.
JAMES PEARCE: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So I'm Chris
[INAUDIBLE].
I'm the tech leader for the
Chrome for Android.
So I think to answer the power
question is Android actually
does have the tools to measure
the power, and they're very
precise, the tools.
The device is called the
[INAUDIBLE] device.
They basically replace the
battery on the phone, and they
measure on the per-amp base
for all the actions.
And then they publish all the
open source how to hook up the
tools with Android platform.
So if you have a web app, you
can run the apps and then to
monitor what action
can trigger it.
So as a developer, I will
suggest the things is try to
not put a lot timers, especially
just because on the
mobile device, when CPU is
running in the high frequency,
it is burning a lot
of battery.
And for the multicore devices,
sometimes they
keep one core working.
But if a CPU working load is
higher, they're going to bring
up more cores.
So the more cores means
more power usage.
And then they have this way is
basically after a couple
milliseconds, no activity,
they're going to
crank down the power.
But if you keep every, say,
two seconds and you fire a
timer yourself and try to
check something in the
background, and if nothing
happened, you sleep.
But the device is going to
basically keep running this
high power mode and
then basically
going to burn the battery.
And also things for the radio
things is every time one radio
is taking a little bit of longer
time to bring up, and
then they normally keep it
in the longer times.
And another case, for
example, as Wi-Fi.
So probably people having device
with the Wi-Fi this
week experienced the bad
experience, bad battery life
in the Moscone center.
Because Wi-Fi bad, so the device
keeps trying to connect
to the Wi-Fi, and then that
also burn the batteries.
JAMES PEARCE: Two minutes?
Got two minutes left?
All right, OK.
We started late.
We are using up time.
So if we could just quickly go
around, I have two questions.
You have 30 seconds to answer
two questions each.
And the first question is if I'm
an average web developer
and I want to take away
something that I can start
doing right now to make my web
apps more performant, what
would that one thing be?
And secondly, if you could cast
a magic spell to make
mobile web performance a better
place, assuming you had
the power of the Google Chrome
team for example, what would
that one thing be?
Go ahead--
30 seconds each.
PAUL BAKAUS: OK, so first thing,
I'm going to give you
an actionable item on actual
improving your perceived
responsiveness of your app but
also saving your battery life.
And that is any time the app
doesn't have anything to do--
for instance if your app
needs a login flow.
So you started a login,
username, password, input--
at that time, do a big network
burst to load all your data in
the background because, after
the user logs in, he will have
all the stuff loaded already.
And the chance is very likely he
doesn't quit the app before
logging in, so that's a great
point in which you should be
loading data.
JAMES PEARCE: And the
one thing you
would fix if you could?
PAUL BAKAUS: The one
thing I would fix
is, let's see, scrolling.
Yeah, give us good scrolling
APIs on Chrome Mobile.
TOM WILTZIUS: You
want the APIs?
PAUL BAKAUS: I want APIs.
Yeah, Microsoft has them.
Chrome doesn't.
TOM WILTZIUS: All right.
I guess my one takeaway would
be that you should be aware
that jank is a problem, and it's
a hard problem to solve.
But we do have some tools
to solve it, and I would
encourage you to check out a lot
of our developer relations
resources on how to use
Chrome's DevTools
to fight that jank.
I gave a talk about this
yesterday, but even basic
tools like Show paint rectangles
or Show composited
layer borders or the Vertical
Timeline go really far.
JAMES PEARCE: And you are the
fairy godmother, so what is
the one thing you can
fix for everybody?
TOM WILTZIUS: Yeah, right.
That's a good question.
I guess I was going to phrase
my answer somewhat
differently, because I wasn't
going to fix something.
I was going to change the
way a lot of the web's
specifications were built so
that we're not stuck in such
complicated scenarios.
JAMES PEARCE: Ah, that counts.
That counts.
Go ahead.
TOM WILTZIUS: There are a lot
of things that we would like
to be able to do that we're a
little bit hemmed in by the
immense, expansive API
service of the web.
So I am happy that on mobile
we've been able to move a
little bit faster.
I want us to be able to move a
little bit faster everywhere.
I think one of the ways we're
going to do that without
actually causing pain by
changing things is by
introducing new primitives into
the web that are going to
allow us to have the
pit of awesome--
the things that are only going
to be fast, but you're going
to be able to do less
inside of them.
We have ideas around, for
instance, infinite list
containers that are just
going to work.
And you won't be able to have
crazy overhanging floats, but
it'll be fast.
And that'll be good.
JAMES PEARCE: Infinite list
controllers in a pit of awesome.
Yeah.
Can we have that by tomorrow?
TOM WILTZIUS: Sure.
JAMES PEARCE: Thank you.
Ilya?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Let's see, so
maybe coming back to perceived
performance, I think that's
a really good point.
And coming back to education
as well, I think developers
should learn about the radio and
how it works, this mobile
radio thing.
Because we keep complaining
about mobile network being
slow, unpredictable, so much
latency, variability.
Once you actually learn
how the basics of
those things work--
you probably need to spend a
couple of hours just reading
about how it works--
you can actually model most
of these high-latency
environments really,
really well.
Anticipate them, and then you
very quickly realize that an
average thing, like an
average request over
3G, will take a second.
That directly tells you
something about how you design
your application, how you
structure, how your UI works
and all the rest.
JAMES PEARCE: Magic wish?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Magic wish--
faster than speed of light
travel, because that would
solve all of our latency
problems.
JAMES PEARCE: That is magical
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
That network performance--
solved.
But I don't think we're
going to get that.
Yeah.
JAMES PEARCE: All right,
well, never mind.
[LAUGHTER]
ARIYA HIDAYAT: So like what Ilya
said, treat performance
as a feature, automate
performance measurement, put
it as part of your development
workflow, CI system, whatever,
even if it's just a
simple smoke test.
Create that git precommit hook
that blocks the check-in if
something gets lower.
JAMES PEARCE: All right,
and the magic wish?
ARIYA HIDAYAT: The
magic wish--
so, more parallelism.
So the Samsung Galaxy S4
Internet Edition this eight
core CPU, a big-LITTLE Endian
and a big-LITTLE architecture.
So I think we're going to see
probably 16 core mobile CPU in
the near future, so more
parallelism in the browser
will be very awesome.
JAMES PEARCE: All right,
that's it.
We're over.
That's a wrap.
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]